Speaker 1: Well, sometimes truth really
is stranger than fiction. This is going
to be hard for many of you to believe, but
the transformation of Alan Dershowitz seems
almost complete. He is now representing
Mypillow CEO and founder Mike Lindell.
Now, when I say transformation in the interview
we're going to look at shortly, Dershowitz says
he's still a liberal Democrat who voted for Biden,
but that he's getting involved in these cases
because of the principles, the legal principles,
etc.. It is a cartoonish mess that pillow is.
And then you add Dershowitz to it, and it is
just some kind of very strange salad of some
kind. I don't even know what words to apply to
it. Here is Dershowitz saying he is going to ask
for a special master for the pillow cell phone.
It's every single one of these things. Couldn't
be a bigger joke. Remember that Mike Pillows phone
was seized by the FBI at a Hardee's drive thru not
long ago. And here is pillow interviewing
his new lawyer. Alan Dershowitz issued.
Speaker 2: A subpoena for the telephone so
that they can get in search of it. And where
is exactly? And what we're seeking is what
President Trump got in the Merrill Largo case, the
appointment of a special investigator to look into
this or return of the cell phone. Because the the
search was a general search, the kind of general
search that the framers of our Constitution wanted
to specifically outlaw in the Fourth Amendment.
Speaker 1: Now, Dershowitz is a lawyer, and so
are Trump's lawyers, Olena Haba and Christina Bobb
and all those people. They made the same argument
after the search warrant was executed at Mar a
Lago. They said this was a fishing expedition.
It was general. They sort of took everything.
There was no discretion. This is unconstitutional.
And then, of course, it didn't actually turn
out that any judge or court agreed with them.
Here is an interview on the Law and Crime
Network, wherein Alan Dershowitz explains,
why are you working for Mike Pillow? Now,
the answer might be because Mike Pillow has
a lot of money. That might be the real answer.
I don't know. But take a listen to some of this.
Speaker 2: Well, thank you. First of all,
let me tell you why I'm representing Mike
Lindell. I agree with him about very little.
I think the election was fair. I think he's
wrong in challenging the election. We're on
completely different sides. I'm a liberal
Democrat. I voted for Biden. He's a conservative
Republican. I think it's critically important
for people on my side of the political
fence, people who are Biden supporters,
supporters of the election to hold the Justice
Department accountable for trying to target our
political enemies. I think the criticism should
come from within our party, not only outside the
party. So I'm very anxious to defend the
Constitution. On behalf of Mike Lindell,
the search itself was clearly a general search.
Speaker 1: Okay. And then he makes the same point
we heard him make in the earlier segment. Now,
listen, here's the story with this. If. How can
I say this? The fact that it took this long for
there to be any action given Trump's consistent
wrongdoing year after year after year, tells us
that if there were really. Any. Biased interest
in how this went down. It's that the FBI and DOJ
were too reluctant to get involved in going after
Trump. So what Pillow and Trump and Dershowitz
want us to believe is the fact that these things
happened at all, that there was the raid on Mar
a Lago, that there was the seizure of pillows,
cell phone. The fact that these things happened at
all is indicative of political bias and attempts
at political retribution. There has been so
much wrongdoing that the way I see it is the
fact that it took this long suggests they were
really reluctant and they wanted to be really
careful and really sure. And of course, all the
evidence we have points that way when you look at
the search warrant for the Mar a Lago. When you
look at the fact that the attorney general signed
off on the FBI director signed off, a judge signed
off, everything was made just so and it didn't
really matter that the Trump is because they still
said it was illegal. It's a political witch hunt.
All these different things, they'll say that
either way. But so far, no court has found that
any of those arguments have merit. My expectation
is that courts will similarly find that.
DERSHOWITZ His arguments about the pillow phone
seizure, pillow phone seizure, those are the terms
we're using will also be without merit. That's
my expectation. We will watch and we will see